[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
grand jt des territoires sur tv5monde et
sur vos chaînes locales et régionales
tout de suite voici les titres de
l'actualité avec à la une les
intempéries sur une partie du territoire
les vosges notamment n'ont pas été
épargnés avec de violents orages et de
la grêle en plein été reportage à suivre
de vosges télévision nationale
et si pour retrouver un emploi vous
deviez mouiller le maillot
dans la loire pour l'emploi vient
d'organiser une journée autour du sport
entre recruteurs et demandeurs d'emploi
une journée qui a suivi la rédaction de
tl7 la télévision de la loire jouer d'un
instrument produire des sons ou écouter
de la musique
la musicothérapie est un moyen reconnu
pour aller mieux
la rédaction de 7 à limoges a pu suivre
une séance dans un ehpad et puis en fin
de journal nous vous ferons découvrir la
folie du esport l'avenir du sport
n'iront certains la principauté de
monaco en tout cas y croit et nourrit de
grandes ambitions pour sa jeune
fédération présidée par louis ducruet le
fils de la princesse stéphanie mollard
maison débute ce journal je vous le
disais avec les intempéries qui ont
encore touché de nombreuses régions en
france mardi notamment les vosges ont
été victimes de violents orages de grêle
un phénomène qui a causé de nombreux
dégâts localement comme a pu le
constater la rédaction de vosges
télévision regarder des images
apocalyptiques
un orage de grêle d'une extrême violence
a traversé les vosges peu avant 10h des
lois en passant par le val d'ajol
plombières les bains direction bruyère
bloquant la route nationale 57 en cette
fin juin 4 chasse-neige sont intervenus
pour dégager la route à commencer par
des grêlons étaient en 10 minutes mais
ça fait une route de glace était avec la
circulation
ça commençait à couches minces à santa
fe un chalet attendons une exploitation
agricole à fresse sur moselle ont pris
la foudre et le centre historique de
plombières les bains s'est transformée
en torrent
tout à l'heure il y avait un tas de un
tas de grêle qui faisait presque deux
mètres de haut donc on a enchaîné a
beaucoup on à aider à déblayer
voilà je viens pour tenir la poste à
plombières est là je tombe à un peu des
nues on a l'impression qu'il fait moins
cinq degrés avec nos petites chaussures
on a quand même assez froid et c'est un
paysage un peu particulier qu'on est en
train de voir la pierre à peu sous le
choc une cellule de crise a été mise en
place en mairie avec une vingtaine de
pompiers des gendarmes organisé pour
recenser les dégâts à quelques jours du
début de la saison touristique tuiles
envolées quasi dans des arbres couchés
ligne électrique au sol et deux blessés
pour la maire du village c'est la
consternation
c'est une scène d'apocalypse aujourd'hui
un plan d aide il est tombé 1 mètre de
hauteur de grêle en quelques minutes
c'était incroyable on n'a jamais vu ça à
la mi journée les pompiers avaient déjà
été mobilisés une centaine de fois une
chaîne spontané de solidarité s'est
créée entre habitants et entreprises du
secteur dans le reste de l'actualité
versailles a accueilli cette semaine la
quatrième édition du sommet choose
france
objectif de ce rendez vous économique
convaincre les grands groupes
internationaux de s'implanter et
d'investir en france 150 dirigeants
participent à l'événement dans
l'enceinte du château de la cité royale
les détails et les explications avec ce
sujet de nicolas landry de la rédaction
de tv 78 dans les yvelines
ils étaient plus d'une centaine de
dirigeants internationaux des têtes
d'affiché comme stéphane bancel pdg de
moderna groupes pharmaceutiques ou
encore jamie dimon pdg de la banque
américaine jp morgan
tous venus au sommet de shoes france
avec un intérêt pour l'attractivité
économique de la france aujourd'hui le
plan de relance est décaissé très
rapidement nous avons déjà engagé plus
d'un tiers du plan de relance
et puis il ya une deuxième série de
questions qui tailleur présage d'autres
investissements dans les mois à venir
c'est sur la décarbonation et sur la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
pour cette quatrième édition du sommet
de shoes france 22 projets
d'investissements ont été annoncée pour
un montant de 3,5 milliards d'euros et
7000 emplois à la clé c'est le cas du
groupe pharmaceutique allemand merck
présent sur 11
sites en france comme grand groupe
mondial du secteur pharmaceutique
nous avons décidé de continuer à
investir dans les capacités de
croissance avec du matériel plus
performant pour soutenir la production
et les clients autour du monde la
principale annoncé l'ouverture dans le
nord de la france d'une usine de
production de batteries pour les
véhicules électriques avec de possibles
répercussions pour le territoire des
yvelines avec l'annoncé de
l'investissement chinois notamment en
matière de batteries
on sait bien que c'est une filière qui
est fondamental pour la filière auto et
qui est une pierre très structurante ici
dans les yvelines
et donc c'est une excellente nouvelle
effectivement de voir que on a des
investissements qui vont aussi in fine
et irriguer le territoire
de son côté la région ile de france mène
aussi une politique pour favoriser
l'attractivité du territoire francilien
nous avons identifié des sites et
notamment des friches industrielles qui
sont prêtes à l'emploi et ses sites
prête à l'emploi nous allons les mettre
à la disposition des patrons nous avons
aussi mis en place une équipe qui est
chargé d'accueillir y compris les
impatriés en 2020 la france reste le
pays le plus attractif d'europe avec 985
projets d'investissements tout à fait
autre chose dans l'actualité après le
baccalauréat les épreuves du brevet
était organisée cette semaine pour
toutes les classes de 3e en france avec
notamment l'épreuve des mathématiques
mardi et c'est pour porter un autre
regard sur cette matière que tous les
ans des collégiens participent au rallye
de mathématiques dans la sarthe les
vingt classes ce finalistes locales se
sont réunies il y a quelques jours pour
un véritable parcours en plein air à
base de jeux et d'énigmes
c'est pas désagréable vous allez le voir
cette année 53 collèges privés et
publics ont participé à la 31ème édition
de l'événement lors virard pour la
rédaction de via lmtv sarthe était sur
place regarder
les mathématiques appliquées c'est pas
si compliqué même le métier de géomètre
devient accessible
alors là ça s'appelle un taquet au
maître on appelle ça une station total
oscillant entre mais ça permet de
mesurer des angles et des distances
france est un petit peu perfectionner un
mais mais à la base c'est c'est comme
les appareils qui utilisent en géométrie
pendant leurs cours de latin toute la
journée les épreuves vont se succéder
pour ses vingt classes finalistes du
rallye mathématiques
il s'est en réalité déroulé toute
l'année dans 53 collèges publics et
privés de la sarthe
et ce n'est pas forcément les plus forts
en maths qui se sont qualifiés parce que
le rallye maths c'est l'organisation qui
fait que les classes vont se qualifier
pour la finale
on peut avoir les très bons élèves si on
les écoute pas si si l'on peut organiser
s'ils n'ont pas le temps de tout faire
la classe sera pas qualifié une seule
réponse par classe
cinq ateliers par man show faut qu'on
mesure la largeur la longueur la
longueur la ce défi en plein air est
organisé pour que les élèves aient
l'impression de jouer et cette équipe
l'a bien compris on s'oublie pas les
unes les autres que tout le monde
travaille ensemble
faire tout pour pas pour gagner mais
pour s'amuser
depuis sa première édition en 1990
l'organisateur de l'événement est
convaincu de la portée pédagogique de
cette journée on est surpris de voir que
des élèves qu'on pensait pas très bon on
se retrouve moteur ce jour là en fait
alors que les options d'autres élèves
sont plus colère et son mouvement un
moteur en fait ça révèle des choses
totalement différentes
le rallye mathématique est à ce jour
l'activité scolaire regroupant le plus
de collégiens en sarthe
tout au long de l'année
nous en parlions en ouverture de cette
édition les orages parfois très violents
n'ont pas épargné la france ces
dernières semaines
mais est il possible de les anticiper
cela paraît compliqué au premier abord
mais une pme française basée à pau en a
fait sa spécialité
michel picaud bonjour c'est notre rendez
vous éco région et vous allez nous
parler aujourd'hui de météorage une
entreprise capable de détecter de suivre
et d'alerter les populations et les
entreprises une heure avant qu'un orage
n'éclate sur une région pas mal bon
cyril bonjour à tous je vous emmène
aujourd'hui à pau pour découvrir
l'entreprise météorage entreprise leader
en europe dans la détection et le suivi
des orages et donc des impacts de foudre
l'entreprise dispose d'un réseau de
capteurs de suivi implantés un peu
partout en europe et qui sont capables
d'alerter tous risques d'orage et donc
d'impacts de foudre
une heure avant que la foudre ne
s'abatte sur le sol
attention il est impossible de définir
précisément où va tomber la foudre mais
ce système d'alerté de prévention permet
d'une part de sauver des vies notamment
auprès des personnes exposées dans les
campings par exemple ou encore sur les
chantiers de btp ou de l'éolien mais
d'autre part
ce système permet d'alerter de
nombreuses entreprises dont la foudre
peut arrêter ponctuellement ou
durablement la production ainsi une
usine par exemple avant l'arrivée dans
l'orage peut enclencher son propre
réseau de production d'électricité pour
éviter la coupure de courant
les groupes électrogènes peuvent aussi
démarré à la proche d'un orage dans son
hôpital ou toute autre entreprise ne
pouvant s'arrêter
ces risques d'arrêt de production
peuvent avoir un impact économique
important sur les entreprises cela
explique peut-être que 60% des
entreprises du cac 40 sont clientes
l'entreprise météorage est extrêmement
innovante elle a été fondée par un
constructeur privé de paratonnerre en
1987 avant de devenir une filiale de
météo france mais cette filiale de 60
personnes est indépendante et elle
poursuit sa croissance externe
elle a d'ailleurs récemment racheté son
concurrent italien et vient de se hisser
leader européen bientôt mondial dans le
domaine du suivi et d' alerte dès orages
enfin depuis le début de cette année
2021 près de deux millions de décharges
électriques de coup de foudre si vous le
voulez sont tombés sur l'ensemble du
territoire
merci michel picaud rendez vous pour une
prochaine édition
avec des nouvelles de l'économie dans
nos régions sur le front de l'économie
toujours les chiffres du chômage sont
restées stables au premier trimestre
selon les données de l'insee dévoilé
cette semaine
à saint-etienne il est conseillé de
chausser les baskets et de faire du
sport pour trouver un emploi pour
l'emploi un club d'athlétisme local et
la métropole de saint-etienne ont
organisé une journée sportive pour
faciliter le recrutement dans une
dizaine d'entreprises de la loire alors
sportif préparez vous une rencontre en
deux temps épreuve sportive et job
dating
adrien bethery a suivi cette journée
pour la rédaction de tl7 la télévision
de la loire vous aussi vous aimeriez
battre votre futur patron à la course
est bien ce matin beaucoup l'ont fait
mais sans le savoir 50 demandeurs
d'emploi se sont donné à 100% pour
impressionner les recruteurs je pense
que c'est une bonne expérience à faire
c'est super franchement il ya de
l'entr'aide on est solidaire ça nous
permet de nous motiver
surtout qu'on sait pas qui est qui et
quoi on va le découvrir cet après midi
quatre équipes ont été formées avec au
moins deux recruteurs par groupe mais en
short et en baskets pas facile de les
retrouver
ça permet à la fois à des demandeurs
d'emploi qui serait un peu coincé sur un
type de recrutement classique et mains
de se libérer complètement est à la fois
aussi ça permet aux employeurs de de
voir d'autres facettes de la
personnalité du candidat potentiel les
épreuves terminées les visages sont
dévoilées en forme sur le tour tout ce
que j'ai vu c'est beaucoup plus
informelle qu'avec des nouveaux parce
qu'en fait on se connaît pas dire des
deux trois heures donc donc c'est plus
un débrief de ce qu'on a vu le matin
parce que ce sport permet de voir plein
de choses
alors après forcément il ya des
personnes qui se sont peut-être un peu
plus démarqué que d'autres qui commet
enfin comme travaillent dans l'aide à la
personne c'est sûr que toutes les
qualités un peu du même type
bienveillance et tout ça c'est vrai que
j'en fais tout de suite le retour est
elle a dit que j'étais sociable non
franchement c'était cool franchement
je l'avais repéré aussi certains ont
fait très bonne impression car il ya
même des coups de coeur ce matin j'ai vu
des choses super avec notamment steve
qui par exemple porter toute épreuve de
sport co c'était un des petits leaders
de l'équipe toujours dans l'antre 1 avec
le sourire en train de taper dans les
mains des néo collègues pour aider etc
et tous ces valeurs-là d'entre elles
dont il peut aller voir mes enfants
faire du sport ensemble
l'opération du stade vers l'emploi qui
se déroule partout en france a déjà
permis à 50 % des participants d'obtenir
un emploi nous nous rendons sa voix à
présent ou des tortues peuvent en chasse
et d'autre le sujet peut faire sourire
mais il est pris très au sérieux dans la
région les tortues dit de floride sont
devenus invasive et empêche les tortues
locale appelée cistude de se développer
dans leur environnement naturel pour
lutter contre le phénomène le
conservatoire des espaces naturels de sa
voix tentent de réguler les tortues
étrangères en recueillant celle des
particuliers
explication micro de luca ruch j'aurais
liste pour la chaîne 8 mont blanc sur
place cela fait des années qu'ils à ce
face à face entre la tortue de floride
dont qui elle vient de fleurir comme son
nom l'indiqué la cistude d'europe qui
elle est la tortue local qu'on a
réintroduit donc en fait on est un peu
l'accent là dessus parce que la tortue
de floride qui a été relâché depuis des
années elle se reproduit maintenant donc
le souci c'est qu'il continue à rien
alors de plus en plus en fait ces deux
espèces ont quasiment le même mode de
vie elles vont se concurrencer
sauf que la tortue de floride est un
petit peu plus costaud a les plus
grosses elle se reproduit plus tôt plus
longtemps et elle va un peu prendre le
dessus sur les zones d'alimentation sur
l'alimentation elle même donc elle va
juste poussé un petit peu la cistude en
dehors de son milieu de vie
la musique comme remède aux maux à
présent dans ce grand jt des territoires
à l'initiative d'un musicien frank
cholly chef d'orchestre et formé à la
musique thérapie le centre communal
d'action sociale de limoges a organisé
une série de séances dans un ehpad
quand la musique fait du bien au corps
et au cerveau c'est à limoges c'est avec
alain dru de la rédaction de cet aliment
je regarde on a besoin de se démener de
d'avoir des contacts gay dans cet
établissement pour personnes âgées
dépendantes la séance est attendu avec
une certaine impatience aujourd'hui nous
allons faire de la musicothérapie
qu'est ce que la musicothérapie donc
dans le mot thérapie qui peut faire peur
j'explique que par exemple que c'est
comme quand on va chez un kiné ils nous
menacent le dos ça fait du bien et on
ressort de la séance on est bien et bien
là avec la musique avec le son par
différentes techniques les personnes
ressortent des séances avec un mieux
être un bien-être duos ont stimulé le
corps le cerveau c'est le quotidien dans
un ehpad aujourd'hui renforcée par
franck qui est là pour faire du bien en
début de séance les gens arrivent
ne sachant pas ce qu'ils vont trouver
donc un petit peu circonspect et petit à
petit ils s'ouvrent ça marche pas sur
tous les résidents mais effectivement
j'ai ressenti lors des précédentes
séances
des personnes qui étaient qui avait pas
mal d'anxiété de stress quand même une
redescente quand même plutôt positive il
faut entre six et dix séances pour
vraiment apporter quelque chose de
durable surtout les gens qu'on ait
troubles du comportement
sur des plumes de la mémoire la séance
se partage entre action et écoute ça m'a
fait beaucoup de bien bas depuis ce que
je trouve que l'on est trop confiné je
trouve quand on ne s'éclate pas assez
réaliser ses rêves
voilà une autre méthode pour prendre
soin de l'esprit et du corps à amiens
l'association chevaux blancs et rêve
doré réalise les rêves des plus de 70
ans
cette semaine c'est yvette benazerah qui
a pu réaliser le sien sauter en
parachute
la tête dans les nuages et les pieds sur
terre regardez ce reportage d'agde à
tous les pour la chaîne hbo la chaîne de
la voix du nord
l'heure du grand sault est arrivé pour
yvette 71 ans après 50 ans attentes
cette septuagénaire habits noise
passionnés de sensations fortes à
réaliser son rêve sauter en parachute
avant de se préparer
yvette admire les avions sans aucune
appréhension à une heure du décollage
les appréhensions pas j'ai vraiment le
sentiment d'avoir déjà sauté j'ai
tellement regardé des choses j'ai
tellement regardé des sceaux ça m'a
toujours poursuivi que non j'y vais
tranquille pour ce rêve qu'elle
n'oubliera jamais yvette a été aidée par
l'association cheveux blancs et rêve
doré l'objectif de ce projet réaliser
les rêves des plus de 70 ans résidant
dans l'agglomération amiénoise là
aujourd'hui on en a company bête dans
son projet et on est très fier parce que
je pense qu'elles représentent à elles
mêmes et à une seule de vraiment tout ce
que nous on défend dans cette
association
c'est qu'il y'a pas d'âge il n'y a pas
il n'y a pas de limite à faire un rêve
ou avoir un souhait il est temps pour
yvette et son moniteur cédric de se
préparer et dans parquet à plusieurs
centaines de mètres d'altitude mais très
très courageuse
la voix soul et je suis très content de
voir c'est parti pour 15 minutes
d'ascension avant de traverser les
nuages et de profiter du paysage
après 8 minutes de vol il va être
atterri en douceur
c'est magique magic trop court mais
magique c'est quelque chose de je vous
le souhaite
impressionnant c'est de sortir de
l'avion après c'est à la bonne heure
mais c'est extraordinaire mais j'avais
un moniteur l'association cheveux blancs
et rêve doré continuera quant à elle
réalisé deux rêves
restons dans le nord de la france dans
ce grand jt des territoires racontait la
vie des habitants de saint quentin et de
son agglomération
c'est le travail au quotidien de la
chaîne locale de la tnt via ma télé ce
média qui diffuse depuis quelques
semaines désormais le grand jt des
territoires l'occasion parfaite pour en
savoir un peu plus sur cette chaîne avec
son président jean luc nelle bonjour
jean luc
bonjour à tous parlez nous de ce média
via ma télé sauf erreur il est assez
jeune dans le paysage médiatique des
chaînes locales la télé s'est créée le
17 mai 2013 il ya donc bientôt une
dizaine d'années elle compte une
douzaine de salariés
elle s'est construite autour de deux
caractéristiques l'hyper proximité qui
constituent le fondement de son concept
éditorial et la mobilité avons mis au
point un bus tuyaux qui enregistrent les
émissions et qui va à la rencontre des
habitants qui enregistre ses émissions
en mobilité
jean luc nelle quels programmes sont
diffusés sur vient ma télé quel secteur
couvrez vous exactement
je vais commencer sans doute par le l'un
des plus populaires c'est l'émission
quotidienne fraîche de chansons
françaises et accordéon avec des
artistes locaux et leurs invités
l'émission s'appelle l'accordéon par
envahie saint-quentin pratique lyme qui
courent tous les sujets
de l'avis saint-quentinoise est
également une deuxième partie qui est
sport live sujet sur les clubs et qui
couvre l'actualité sportive du
territoire avec toujours une
caractéristique qui est celle de ma télé
qui est de donner la parole aux
habitants du territoire jean luc nelle
al'approche de l'été une grille spéciale
va-t-elle se mettre en place sur votre
antenne
nous ne diffusons le grand jt tout l'été
bien sûr cet été les équipes sont au
repos et la grille de la télé pour la
période estivale sera essentiellement
constitué de rediffusion de tous les
meilleurs moments de l'année et de ce
qu'a pu vivre le territoire sur lequel
nous émettons mater quelles nouveautés
attendent vos téléspectateurs pour la
rentrée c'est une question qu'on se pose
des changements sont ils à prévoir une
grande nouvelle c'est que ma télé des
ménages dont sept étaient trouvera de
nouveaux locaux évidemment les grands
directs sportifs seront repris et
continue et donc une émission qui était
celle du bus on se voit bientôt
reprendra à la rentrée avec l'itinérance
de son but studio merci jean luc nelle
pour vos réponses et bon courage donc
pour cette rentrée dans vos nouveaux
locaux je rappelle que vous êtes le
président de la chaîne locale via ma
télé sur la tnt
une chaîne qui couvre le bassin
d'audience de saint quentin dans le
département de l'aisne et qui diffuse le
grand jt des territoires sans transition
partons à la découverte du phénomène de
l'ispor soit le sport électronique
si monaco est connue pour son grand prix
de formule 1 son tournoi tennis ou
encore son équipe de foot
la principauté pourrait aussi bientôt
devenir une terre de l'ispor ces
compétitions de jeux vidéo en public ou
en ligne font désormais des millions
d'adeptes à travers le monde
la fédération monégasque compte bien
faire briller la principauté dans cette
discipline à l'international un
reportage et des explications de
christophe rigaud qui a rencontré louis
ducruet le fils de la princesse
stéphanie de monaco qui est président de
la fédération monégasque de l'ispor
regarde
fortnight league of legends fifa les
compétitions de jeux vidéo sont devenus
un véritable phénomène de société qui
rassemble aujourd'hui plus de 500
millions d'internautes à monaco où son
grand prix de f1 et son tournoi de
tennis sont mondialement reconnus la
principauté entend bien profiter de cet
engouement pour jouer les premiers rôles
c'est un nouveau sport un sport jeune
qui est en train de prendre sa place
dans le l'environnement sportif mondial
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est le
moment d'attraper le train pour le
esport en principauté un club de ea
sports a été créé en 2014 puis une
fédération en 2017
le club forme les joueurs pour les
compétitions travaille avec eux la
stratégie et les prépare mentalement et
physiquement
car oui le hisse porte est bien un sport
comme les autres il ya quand même des
aspects sportifs qui sont assez
impressionnants dedans comme les reflex
l'endurance
tous ces choses là qui font que
aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'on a du mal à
se faire à se faire comprendre par
certaines générations
monaco compte bien attirer sur le rocher
les plus grandes compétitions de jeux
vidéo l'an dernier la principauté a
rejoint la fédération internationale du
sport et des discussions sont engagées
pour organiser de grandes compétitions
comme la coupe du monde
on veut vraiment viser l'international
dû fait du rayonnement de monaco donc
c'est vrai qu'on est un peu restreint de
par la taille du territoire
mais on a la chance d'avoir une
visibilité qui intéresse beaucoup de
gens c'est pour ça que tous les
prochains événements au sein de la
principauté
on voit est orienté l'international donc
avec des casteurs anglais est une des
joueurs anglophones dernier objectif de
la fédération dit ce porte monégasque
participer au giro lorsque la discipline
sera reconnue sports olympiques et c'est
bien parti
le cio envisage des jeux virtuels pour
les jeux de 2028
et ce week-end c'est le premier grand
départ des vacances d'été à la montagne
dans les terres où les bords de mer à
chacun ses vacances bien sûr et dans la
région occitanie des hôtels flottants
viennent d'ouvrir les îlots de gruissan
vous allez le voir du nom de la station
balnéaire de l'aude amarré dans le port
ses hôtels proposent aux voyageurs une
expérience originale les sensations d'un
bateau et le confort d'une maison quand
même écouter ces quelques réactions au
micro de clément gaz
si du journal la dépêche du midi notre
partenaire sur place les produits
touristiques notamment sur un ca de
l'occitanie d'arrestation jeu oser le
dire se ressemblent quand même puisqu'on
est conçu du même moule de la mission
racine dans les années 60
maintenant il faut arriver à se
différencier il faut apporter de
l'insolite de la nature de
l'environnement et de la taille humaine
on voulait un cadre agréable et
on est tombé sur cette location et voilà
enfin là vous voyez le site il est bien
il est fabuleux puisque l'on dort sur
l'eau et avec un soleil lever de soleil
couché de soleil c'est c'est top
voilà de bien bonnes idées de vacances
et on referme ce grand jt des
territoires avec des messages d'amour et
d'espoir dans la gare de toulouse
c'est l'initiative bienveillante qui a
débuté dans la gare centrale de la ville
rose passagers et passants sont ainsi
invités à compléter la phrase suivante
sur un mur demain j'aimerais une idée
qui résonne avec l'actualité s'exprimer
en attendant le train un reportage de
maëlys figuier pour vyas occitanie
regarder à défaut de s'embrasser
déclarer votre fougue à travers la plume
ou plutôt la craie ici sur le parvis de
la gare de toulouse un mur d'expression
vient d'être inauguré inscrivez vos
messages d'amour d'espoir ou de joie de
tous les gens soient heureux sur terre
parce que la vie est courte et je pense
que ça serait bien que le monde en
profite
le tableau est expérimenté depuis un
mois chaque jour les phrases sont prises
en photo pour être analysées par un
expert scientifique puis elles sont
effacées pour laisser place à de
nouvelles le lendemain bel état d'esprit
il est assez positif à ses pleins
d'espoir que ce soit sur la partie
sentimentale que ça soit partie des
rencontres des voyages des passions on a
beaucoup de messages qui permettent de
montrer que ben en tout cas ces murs
d'expression donne des messages
d'encouragement et sans plus tôt à
connotation positive
voilà c'est la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci de l'avoir suivi sur
nos chaînes locales et régionales et sur
tv5 monde
on se retrouve pour une prochaine
édition au revoir à tous et bon courage
[Musique]